Делать не делать или пахать или не
пахать весь мир не такой какой он есть
Да весь мир такой какой ты есть сидела
молилась и хотела вот квадратный
телевизор просто попасть у тебя Каса
миллиард 760 все люди со стороны смотрят
и говорят оба Вот это успех Я понял что
мы сейчас заканчиваем строить ракету на
которой хотим взлететь села и думаю
неужели это вся моя жизнь не девиз
пахать надо только в спортзале чем
больше движений тем меньше приб Я сейчас
думаю а мне рассказывать или нет
[музыка]
друзья я приветствую вас на очередном
выпуске МБО подкаст Сегодня у нас
очередной выпуск который посвящён
теме пахать или не пахать или как
достигать крутых результатов с
наименьшим приложением усилий Но сегодня
гости нашего гем подкаста поделятся как
раз своими знаниями лайфхаками того как
они добились свою очередь своих успехов
может быть эта формула неправильна может
наоборот надо Пахать и пахать а может не
надо вообще не пахать и вот мы сегодня
попытаемся ответить на этот вопрос и
найти эту золотую средину когда пахать
сколько пахать надо ли вообще пахать или
не надо пахать чтобы достигать успеха и
мы сегодня как раз поговорим ещё о том
как каждый из участников гем подкаста
для себя понимает что такое успех и
вообще к чему вам стоит стремиться ещё
раз напомню формат нашего гемба подкаста
на этот гем подкаст мы не собираем
экспертов Хотя среди нас они есть
а но мы специально не собираем экспертов
мы собираем людей с разных сфер отраслей
вы сегодня увидите И поймёте когда
каждый из участников будет
представляться Наша задача
первоначальная задумка была вот собрать
людей это как Посиделки на кухне но с
одной лишь разницей что мы говорим на
одну конкретную тему которая интересна
обществу и мы даём разные взгляды на
популярную тему и таким образом когда
каждый участник делится своим опытом и
своими мыслями Я уверен у вас сложится
нормальная правильная картинка и так
гм подкаст это если переводить с
японского языка это гемба то место где
происходит проблема или гемба - это то
место где принимается решение
по решению этой проблемы и мы берём
поэтому основные злободневные темы и
пытаемся на месте как бы принять решение
Надеюсь это будет эффективно и принесёт
вам пользу Итак начинаем у нас по
традиции Первое это представление
и мы можем начать слева направо а ну по
отношению к зрителям это справа налево
нуно Вот давайте так каждый
представляется 2-3 минуты Чем занимается
откуда там какие достижения Чем гордится
и так далее во-первых Рахмет что позвали
Приветствую всех зрителей Рахмет маки за
то что пригласил меня зовут Алмас жали Я
являюсь предпринимателем и продюсером в
прошлым юристом американской компании Wi
Case Собственно как я пришёл в
блогерский мир
то что помогал бесплатно блогерам разным
юридическим вопросам ко только появляюсь
как блогеры открывать п счета и прочие
вещи вот в ПМ году и дто году их так
много стало разных креативных ребят под
менеджментом что решил открывать свою
компанию уже которая называется сечас и
Мы начинали если начинали с инфлюенсеров
и их представление их интересов то
сейчас уже вот снимаем фильмы Наш первый
полнометражный филь это кой
вышел хоши помо я пря с удовольствием
посмотре Рахмет Да мы его сняли на 30
лет Независимости была наша скажем своя
своего рода точка за эти 30 лет сняли
залили бесплатно в сеть абсолютно Мы
даже партнёрскую принципиально не
подключали YouTube партнёрку не хотели
Никаким образом зарабатывать а только
вот подарить народу скажем кому-то
понравилось кому-то нет но в любом
случае это наша была первая работа и вот
недавно в прошлом году в конце года
случился наком опять же первый
кинотеатра дебют Хоррор фильм D такой
триллер Хоррор тоже он стал самым
кастовым кино за всю историю Казахстана
казахского кино Казахстанского кино и
вот в этом году мы продолжаем да ещё
планироваться два две картины фильма дар
сколько если ровно лрд 760 то есть о мир
760.000 тенге А ребята сделали на фильме
Это самый кассовый фильм на казахском
языке в истории Казахстана Да круто так
Рахмет Рахмет Боше это заслуга всей
нашей команды и ну непосредственно
режиссёра хека помимо этого мы работая с
инфлюенсерами в маркетинге поняли что
можно долго рекламировать продукты наших
клиентов компании в какой-то момент мы
решили что мы можем создавать и свои
продукты Таким образом мы пришли к
созданию бренда под Кузни мама знает B
мо bab женская гигиена EV сейчас у нас
планируется бытовая химия мама знает
маски EV fmcg продук
сейчас очень углубились в это и вышли
уже вот Казахстан Узбекистан и Кыргыстан
там партнёрский принцип работы в
принципе это вот основные наверное виды
деятельности которым занимаемся на нашей
команда
круто Меня зовут Анжелика кайратова Я
приехала из Кыргызстана Да и я медийная
личность на протяжении 26 лет пою
эстрадная певица актриса телеведущая
а в 12 лет веду свои авторские реалити
проекты а также основатель пятнадцати
действующих бизнесов Круто Кру Да вот
занимаемся Да так вот инфлюенсер больше
себя как не как блогер а больше как
инфлюенсерами чувствуется и
журналистский почерк и актёрский почерк
И вообще
прям даже и вроде блог для женщин я так
смотрю Я у меня с точки зрения такого
профессионального интереса Я думаю надо
же как она подмечает детали даже когда
она делала рил истори по Бразилии Я же
вроде тоже по Бразилии ездил по тем же
местам но я не вижу то что она видит
поэтому это очень круто и
профессионально Ну это наверное то что я
с детства снимаюсь в клипах и есть
наверное да свой взгляд и мы вот как
творческие люди мы ВС
замечаем Виталь Иногда приходится так
снимать рассказывать об этом обширно и
вот у нас эта сторона творческая права
сторона Вы наверно заметили А здесь
циники и прагматики сидят А ну-ка
давайте представим эту сторону Да Всем
добрый вечер прежде всего конечно каждый
Казахстанец уважающий человек знает кто
такой марг Лан колеч и сегодня Ну сразу
хочу сказать тоже У нас есть такой
проект 100 книг на казахском языке
вообще я являюсь инициатором площадки GV
Team жексен Васильевич команда в
партнёрстве с Багдад дарба Ева то есть
мы вдвоём с ней начали такой проект 3
года назад Хотя старта нули чуть раньше
знакомства Ну 3 года
назад основная задача это его основная
вот месседж акселератор бизнеса то есть
мы считаем что наш вот значит сегмент в
котором мы стоим это средний бизнес и
малый
бизнес мы ребята девушки которые
начинают бизнес очень часто сталкиваются
с проблемой нуни без Наставников Да и
очень часто сталкиваются с проблемой
тратят очень много времени чтобы вот эту
долину смерти пройти я сам
профессиональный управленец и в
Казахстане строил все крупнейшие нац
компании где-то в Казахстане примерно 60
компаний строил в разных отраслях
примерно в 1 отраслях и в общем-то вот
миссия наверно всей сказана
что содействовать
развитию акселерации бизнеса и вот этот
проект 100 книг в частности Дело в том
что сейчас у нас идёт чёткая
трансформация перехода отечественного
менеджмента на государственный язык и
они сталкиваются с большой проблемой
информационной поддержки вот знаний книг
и так далее И вот такой проект вот
значит маглан Калиевич профинансировал
одну из таких книг вот да у toa вот
сегодня показывали об этом мы нуно
вообще Если говорить о задаче то мы
считаем что очень важная задача - это
сфокусироваться на небольшой группе
людей на небольшой значит акцентировать
внимание для того чтобы стать
акселератора бизнеса развития и так
далее поэтому охватывая все регионы
онлайн есть малый бизнес молодёжные ниши
развиваемся двигаемся и ещё раз основные
все тренера - это с бизнес-школ основное
отличие наверное то что это такой скажем
мини MBA краткосрочные курсы которые
дают минимальный тот набор джентльмена
который позволяет человеку сделать такой
Квантовый скачок круто
Бат
я первая моя ипостась я являюсь
венчурным
инвестором с большим интересом этим
занимаюсь вот с марла Калиевич у нас
несколько проектов есть где мы совместно
проинвестировать кстати наверное
единственный человек который своё время
когда-то пытался два или три раза
устроиться на работу клану Калиевич ни
разу не прошёл Ты пытался Дада Ну я
проходил собеседование я заходил вот но
у него был очень на разных этапах разных
компаниях всегда был очень Разный подход
поэтому Ну наверное это и хорошо потому
что ну на каком-то этапе жизни у нас всё
равно Судьба свела Я очень счастлив
находиться здесь вот венчурная
инвестиция - это такая нельзя назвать
работой меня часто супруга спрашивает
почему ты там на работу не идёшь говорю
у меня мыслительный процесс Вот и Один
из таких вот проектов про которые я могу
сейчас рассказать продолжение вот
разговора о казахском языке это мы
сейчас с моим партнёром буквально из
того что было создали прототип языковой
модели мки казахской irb gpt А и это был
абсолютно такой авантюрный Проект С
одной стороны но с другой стороны это
взлетело заработало И сейчас мы видим
как какой-то имеет потенциал по сути
часть gpt только казахский вариант да Ну
ещё пока в очень граничной версии но
очень классный таки назер получился Ну и
когда ты начинаешь обучать модель ты не
знаешь что получится потому что никто не
знает как её обучить правильно и то есть
себя таких в роли СВ анов казахских
попробовали Прим два человека которые
один вообще не гражданин Казахстана
Второй неговорящий по-казахски Но тем не
менее Вот двигаем эту тему Очень круто и
вторая мо второе моё увлечение нельзя
нать тоже работы Я люблю очень строить
что-то но что-то необычно я
строю такой вот город на воде пото я
семей и подарить им качественную
счастливую жизнь
долгую в том месте где по-настоящему
чистый воздух где будет правильная
комьюнити правильные ценности я сам
разработал макеты домов одноэтажных
безопасных с точки зрение сейсмики и
полностью занимаюсь этим проектом от А
до Я там сами делаем производим
материалы строительные
и постараемся сделать это фи Это я
называю это такой как красоти
ЗМ своим детям говорю что это моя вот
личная концепция когда ты находишь
какое-то очень некрасивое место или
что-то очень не гармоничное пытаешься
вопреки всей энтропии Да которая на
которой строится наш мир сделать что-то
Яркое и
красивое это вдохновляет
и у итальянского
философам город солн
своя Мета большая идея понял большая
идея
такая Интересно что когда я её начинал
даже самые близкие люди относились к
этому как безумию какому-то это всегда
так потому что это показа хороший идеи в
плохом месте но я сказал что я ВС равно
буду строить там ну создали Каскад озёр
а потом
притянул хорошим местом и ситуация пере
бук
го сегодня очень разнообразный состав
участников и причём каждый из них
успешен в своей сфере и как раз я их
пригласил для того чтобы именно обсудить
как они к этому пришли а саму механику И
вообще ответить на этот извечный вопрос
как делать не делать или пахать или не
пахать при этом всем хочется достигать
успеха Но вот вопрос как мы сегодня
будем это обсуждать и Для начала я думаю
чтобы понимать пахать или не пахать
нужно понимать Ради чего Ну Мы все знаем
что все мы хотим достичь успеха но
Каково ваше понимание или определение
успеха что в вашем случае Вы
воспринимаете как успех вот для того
чтобы к чему-то стремиться Нужно же
сначала понять что для тебя является
успехом Давайте посмотрим цель Да вы
имеете в виду ну не то что цель а как
вот ты считаешь Вот это успешно или вот
это успех или неуспех вот даже то что
сегодня достиг например А твой фильм
дастур Угу Угу а успех Ну для людей все
воспринимают лрд 760 млн выручка - это
Успех А для тебя это так или не так а и
начну с фундаментов одна из причин
почему я сижу в кепке наверное впервые в
жизни побрился на волосы не Дума
пересадил волосы в Турции Нет
нет А у меня есть знакомые которые
пересадили волосы в начале ходят в
кепках Нет не я вот тут наверное
последний раз да впервые в жизни
побрился на Лос потому что был последние
10 дней Рамадана на умре
а что вы накра Ну да но не ещё не
привычно тем более в кадре Поэтому решил
чуть-чуть пока они Отрастут так ходить и
я к чему это говорю к тому что наверное
всё ещё нахожусь под
влиянием тех новых знаний либо
укрепления тех знаний которые были до
этого во время умры и соответственно я
сильно
пересмотрел какие-то свои взгляды в
каких-то утвердился наоборот поэтому
наверное я немножко байст буду сейчас
говорить Что такое успех да возможно
через там когда я буду боле погружён в
Дуню через годики Я может по-другому
ответил бы или бы до умры но сейчас вот
уверен все знают вот Сура АСР туаль АСР
и там вот как раз таки про успех все все
Те кто не верует не делают праведные
деяния я не дословно говорю как я это
понял с Да все в
убытке неважно Какой фильм снял есть
правильные деяния Вера во Всевышнего и
так далее Это очень базовая и
поверхностная ответ на Что такое успех и
он наверное очень такой как будто бы я
супер религиозный я я верующий Но не
супер религиозный но при этом я не могу
ответить иначе пото что это фундамент
успеха довольствия Всевышнего наверное и
тянуться к этому довольствию А в моём
случае как думаю каждый человек Он
занимается тем что любит И что умеет и
каждый к этому удовольствию доходит
по-своему есть условно люди большие
имамы которые посредством знаний науки
доходят именно исламской науки доходят
удовольствие Всевышнего кто-то
преподаватель в школе
это ученики и их успех успех
преподавателя для меня как для
предпринимателя
наверное роль в социуме заключается в
том чтобы очень просто зарабатывать
помогать я по-другому не вижу я не
создаю
какие-то зарабатывает помогает условно
сейчас к примеру Кука строит школу
креативную школу хочет построить Я
надеюсь иншалла получится помочь вот
твоя роль есть Альма матор с которого
вышел помочь этому вузу есть школа от
которой вышел там помочь Угу и
соответственно звучит грубо но у меня
один раз партнёр мой в бизнесе Арман
бердина сказал Алмаз говорит мы с тобой
далеко не самые большие скажем святые
люди поэтому всё что мы можем сделать -
это купить рай по-хорошему это так много
заработать для того чтобы так много
построить и помочь людям поэтому я
абсолютно с ним в этом Согласен не буду
пытаться глубоко хорошо ответить поэтому
как бизнесмен Да наверное вот наша роль
успех заключается именно в этом кайф это
беспрерывный процесс на самом деле клас
мы будем отвечать кросно чтобы в одну
сторону это чтобы всё в эту сторону не
ушло и не в эту сторону так тогда кнн
Васильевич Да ну у меня тоже есть своя
точка зрения на этот
вопрос вообще я говорю всегда что
предшествовало созданию вот этого
стакана Да Идея то есть я считаю что
весь мир не такой какой он есть Да весь
мир такой какой ты есть и Мо убеждение
что человек - это три вещи да то есть
коне разные классификации есть Ну это
первое - это знание Да понятно что вот
второе это прочитанные книги там на опыт
и так далее второе - это программное
обеспечение то есть убеждения
всевозможные которые ты приобрёл или
тебе насадили в школе и так далее И
третье там это гормоны Да скажем это
гормоны которые на нас там влияют очень
сильно и я считаю что Счастье это когда
тебе хорошо
счастье упе это цель плюс счастье да то
есть когда ты
достигает достиг вот этой цели ты
получаешь Вот это счастье
удовлетворённость вот там такое слово
Сатисфакция Да удовлетворён ты понял
короче говоря и это тебе даёт вот это
опять же там там есть икигай да И вот
этот который заставляли тебя каждое утро
вставать двигаться и если тебе вот вот я
всегда говорю вот на занятиях когда ты
выступаешь то если человек слушает тебя
если ты ему нравишься то каждое слово
прям залетает Да если ты ему не
нравишься короче хохо ему там Говори Там
там ЧМ угодно просто не заходит к нему и
так далее поэтому моё глубочайшее моё
личное убеждение в том
что Успех - это когда ты вот понял вот я
понял вот мне хорошо вот я всегда говорю
вот слушателям вот у вас есть Например
мама Она говорит да А как ты узнал что
она самая красивая Она же самая красивая
женщина на земле Вот как ты определил
потому что у тебя есть вот это чувство
удовлетворённости вот душа - Это вся
тьма вещей Да ты вдруг понял что вот что
это красиво что это хорошо потому что у
каждого из нас есть своё понятие счастья
у каждого из нас там кого-то там такая у
кого-то такая Там и так далее но
конечная цель - это когда я ложусь встаю
вот с каким-то чувством радости понял
мне хочется ля я очень много людей знаю
кто э для кого-то счастье - это большие
деньги то есть вот это успех он очень
жёстко свя Со счастьем очень жёстко
связан хорошая реплика Угу замечание и
ты вот должен понимать что Когда кто-то
достиг успеха в деньгах Вот для него это
вот успех в этом для кого-то успех там в
картинах для кого-то в чём-то другом но
у каждого успех свой Да а что для вас
для меня Успех - это когда ты каждое
утро встаёшь счастливым удовлетворённым
вот ты вот достиг какой-то цели и достиг
её вот и Вот потому что когда
шься назад и если этот день похож на
вчерашний то он какой-то вот бестолковый
какой-то день да Вот вот и я всегда
всегда каждое утро себе говорю Вот если
вот это позаимствовал у Стив Джобса он
сказал вот если бы ты считал бы этот
день последний в твоей жизни ты хотел бы
вот так его день прожить и вот я каждый
день себе когда конец дня заканчивается
я себе благодарю Да что вот ты чего-то
достиг что ты куда-то продвинулся вот
это для меня успех
Анжелика Ну для меня успех начинается с
намерения это вот т у нас да С П лет я
помню как просто вот сидела молилась и
хотела вот в Квадратный телевизор просто
попасть чтобы меня узнавали лет 5 лет Да
че себе мама научила читать суры и так
как бабушка которая ну тайне умерла 3
годика Когда мне было 3 годика я так те
с ней общаться разговаривать и всё
пришло наверное с того что я научилась
сначала молиться обращаться к ней
рассказывать все свои секреты и за этим
я всегда рассказывала ей мечты Угу и
были такие намерения что я хочу стать
популярной известной чтобы я помогала
людям 5 лет это 5 лет и с 16-1 лет Когда
уже осознанность ещё пришла я уже начала
читать намаз и я об этом никому не
рассказывала Это был такой маленький
секрет но оказывается намерение было
такое что я хочу а быть не на Ну не
столько как популярной Да а полезной
чтобы люди ко мне приходили со мной
советовались чтобы я им помогала и была
нужной фигурой наверное и успех для меня
- это как путеводитель и с другой
стороны вот как Ты прикасаешься
успешному человеку Да что-то открывается
для тебя новая дверь и новый мир и даже
вот сижу здесь среди успешных людей я
просто как будто вот как пушинка Да в
облаках вот летаю и такой кайф это вот
клас когда тебя окружают успешные люди
Да и ты стремишься
постоянно идти вот вверх туда где
создаются успехи или создают успехов да
такие вот люди как
А менторы у которых сейчас Мы учимся и
вот у нас в Кыргызстане какда и в
Казахстане многие сейчас хотят попасть
на такие семинары успешных людей там
наличное наставничество да как сейчас
очень стало модно и это всё благодаря
наверное успеху из-за того что наверное
существует такая вот классная формула
куда стремиться и это даёт надежду чтобы
ты не сидела А пахала и стремилась туда
чтобы приобрести Билет или быть среди
них так Бах Ну я то я поддерживаю этот
тезис о том что Успех - это всё-таки
быть нужным Я это как ощущаю
Что например с позиции моих детей
которых у меня
четверо для меня очень важно
чтобы Мои
дети получили допустим хорошее
образование Угу Или они стремились к
чему-то что на самом деле будет иметь
важную ценность в их жизни а для этого
ты должен сам всегда соответствовать
какому-то
стандарту который их будет вести в эту
сторону и реализоваться это может
совершенно по-разному Например я каждый
день Вот выделяю время там 6 до се когда
я играю с младшим сыном лет совершенно
сумасшедшие игры но он ждёт Папочка
Когда ты придёшь он бросает планшет
бросает все свои дела Что просто
поиграть со мной и это модель общества
на самом деле и с кем-то ты можешь
просто поговорить и поиграть как с
ребёнком кому-то нужна будет твоя помощь
как автора шикарного продукта А кому для
кого-то ты нужен как наставник для
кого-то ты нужен просто Как пример и вот
э вот жизнь
когда ты востребован Она наверное есть
Успех это процесс постоянный и я считаю
что Ну я как как я для себя решаю эту
задачу быть успешным я стараюсь быть
здоровым потому что я для себя вывел
такую формулу
что я могу быть успешным только если я
нахожусь в правильных отношениях с
реальностью умею её правильно
считывать правильно интерпретировать э
реальность для
себя а это позволяет там для семьи
зарабатывать Это позволяет сын приходит
ко мне в офис делать уроки он говорит
папа какой ты крутой что ты со причастен
к такому красивому офису То есть даже
такие вещи
они дают тебе силы для того чтобы
вставать это
мигаем делать что-то дальше поэтому
Успех это больше про Это наверно Кай мы
сечас увидели четыре определения успеха
для каждого вот для алмаза - это
довольствие Всевышнего а для Ксена это
просыпаться каждое утро счастливым из-за
достигнутых каких-то достижений а для
Анжелики это находиться в среде успешных
людей то есть она отзеркаливает от среды
определяет через среду и для Бахта это
быть полезным для других А вообще эта
тема на самом деле большая давайте я
отрезе чтоб нам двигаться дальше я
вообще делю
Успех на две составляющие две большие
составляющие Первая Большая составляющая
успех с точки зрения меня и успех с
точки зрения Общества А дело в том что
мы всегда существуем Вот в этих
двух ипостасях двух па парадигмах
проблема многих молодых людей в том что
они не знают что для них является
успехом и они гоняются за тем успехом
который ему навязала общество А Общество
обычно это социальные сети это там
Bentley это Lamborghini ламбы там крутые
дома Дубай самолёты и так далее но это
успех с точки зрения общества вот в
твоём случае Например у тебя касса
миллиард
760 все люди со стороны смотрят и
говорят оба Вот это Успех А ты это может
быть даже не воспринимаешь для тебя
другое понимание успеха Поэтому нужно
чётко понимать что успех состоит из двух
частей первый успех в глазах общества а
он как правило формируется тем что
общество или минирующая в обществе
мораль считается ценным Что считает
ценным Сегодня у нас в обществе
ценностью являются деньги значит Чем
выше ка тем ты успешней человек если
мораль является деньги то если ты
миллиардер то ты успешный человек и так
далее а а вот с точки зрения человека
личного это очень важный Аспект Каждый
человек должен для себя определить что
такое успех для него само если говорить
в моём случае то для меня я успех
успехом считаю эффективную реализацию
своей миссии У меня есть миссия я я её
для себя определил и у меня прям
конкретные метрики которые определяют
насколько я успешен в реализации своей
миссии И когда ты это делаешь
реализовывать свою миссию то ты как бы
отключаешься от вот этого понятия
общественного успеха и ты не зависишь от
общественного мнения Вот давайте Хорошо
Мы определились с успехом теперь при
этом так или иначе у каждого своё мнение
каждый стремится своему успеху в Вот
наверное отличие успешных реально
успешных людей в данном случае вас
заключается в том что вы ни один из вас
не назвал успехом то что общество
считает успехом То есть вы назвали
именно то что для вас является успехом и
это кстати очень такой важный маркер
показатель потому что я заметил что как
правило неуспешные люди Они для для себя
определяет успехом то что общество
считает успехом То есть у него нету
своего понимания успеха и он когда я
спрашиваешь если человек не знает что
для него реальный успех он начинает
перечислять машины миллиарды там дома и
так далее Давайте теперь поймём такую
вещь понятно что для достижения успеха
нам нужно что-то
делать Вопрос Давайте такой
первый что вот вы делали в своей жизни
для достижения того успеха который у вас
сейчас есть И насколько вы поддерживаете
эту точку зрения пахать не пахать Угу
Вот
это ну насколько вот я хочу проверить
ваши убеждения не то что проверить Я
хочу услышать ваши убеждения Я знаю
просто ребят которые у которых есть
прямая связь они говорят Чем больше я
пошу тем больше результатов всё другой
вариантов других вариантов нет они прямо
связывают с похо той А есть люди на
расслабоне на Чили так сказать у меня
среди учеников тоже такие они говорят
вообще не парятся по поводу работы и у
них как-то всё само собой получается вот
как Как ваше
мнение не то чтобы мнение наверное
текущий
опыт в отличие от старших товарищей всех
наверное которые уже состоялись сидящие
за столом я ежже состоялся Нет ну
всё-таки я сущест 30 лет помладше и
скажите долю долю труда Или пахоты в
вашем Успехе опять же я обязательно хочу
ремарку сделать что все мы знаем да от
нас причины результат от
Всевышнего в этом есть безусловно
большая убеждённость а доля если опять
же разделять
теперь труда было очень много в самом
деле И сейчас наверное как я чувствую
себя во всех проектах так вот как я
уверен вы приводили эти примеры в
своих наставничества Это пример ракеты
либо самолёта взлетающего то есть ракета
когда взлетает она в атмосфере Да пока
она не достигнет не пролетит стратосферу
она выдаёт очень много очень мно о может
взорваться но при этом самый большой
эффорт делается именно до достижения до
прохождения стратосферы там уже
начинается невесомость и там уже
двигаешься легче так
скажем я вот нахожусь в моменте думал
для себя как раз перед этим подкастом
Где мы находимся взлетаем либо уже Я
понял что мы сейчас заканчиваем строить
ракету на которой хотим влететь очень
пессимистично наоборот это же говорит о
каких амбициях если сейчас всё что у нас
есть это всего лишь строительство ракеты
какие у нас Большие цели если какая
будет тогда стратосфера какая будет
какой будет космос и так далее Потому
что очень большие цели Иншаллах Это
очень даже страшно подумать Да и Ну
опять же не наших руках все эти
результаты поэтому пахали ли при этом
Пашем ли
Пашем очень сильно Я наверное из тех кто
убеждён что нужно пахать всё-таки уверен
что и у вас Мар колеч и у вас будут
ответы где всё-таки мы придём к тому что
я я слышал и Джек ма который сказал что
оказывается Стив Джобс но видимо я ещё в
той потому что они вы и они видите
картину уже наверное со стороны по
достижению каких-то результатов я ещё
внутри этой игры и для меня пахать
пахать пахать я сейчас готов умереть на
станке я пытаюсь войти во все не
микроменеджмент
[музыка]
какая-то доля перфекционизма и если
сейчас мы в начале ракету правильно не
построим то каким образом мы достигнем
того что мы достигнем да то есть сейчас
мы не можем халатно её начать продолжать
строить потому что вот такой весь из
себя холдер я балансируют либо фило сост
на эту тему опять же я задаю тренд своей
компании по поводу этой пахоты
соответственно с учётом опыта когда
работал там параллельно учился на Бакала
третий четвёртый курс юрфака и вёл Жеку
атли сабиркин как этих Как как менеджер
вот тогда этот период Как как тогда я
уже никогда не пахал но Темп был задан И
в чём наверное идеология пропаганды
американских фирм таких как нкейс когда
ты работаешь До 5:00 утра каждый день
там же би А ты же выставляешь часы и
каждый твой час он там условно у меня
там 500 долларов стоит к примеру и чем
больше ты за билил в конце года ты
получаешь бонус больше Но тогда меня
даже не деньги интересовали а больше
именно продвижение по карьерной лестнице
учитывая что там лет прошёл в фирму Угу
поэтому мы же не с неба свалились Мы все
продукты тех или иных событий в нашей
жизни а учитывая что весь сй
студенческий
пропахали из Назарбаев университета Я
поступил полгода проучился меня
исключили и меня отец заставил работать
на авторынке сто авторынок моторного
масла и там была пахота то есть всю
жизнь с детства была пахота почему с
университета исключили я буйный парень
был А понятно Это не связано с похо той
Я думал не до пахал не не это не связано
с хотой
наоборот А
поэтому у меня очень простое убеждение
что нужно пахать если на вопрос
правильно прямо ответить Я прошу и пока
я не вижу вот того Вот что за холмом за
холмом когда перестают пахать я этого не
вижу и пока я думаю ладно что смотреть
Всё у нас есть одна точка зрения пахать
надо вавич Ну Вторая точка зрения может
быть тоже какие-то конгру ЕНТ вообще
очень вопрос очень сложный както как-то
мы студентами были и Мы как-то собрались
и в комнате и один говорит Вот такая
история говорит э у меня ка одини
знакомый первые миллионеры появились
сейчас много богаты тогда
полиська короче вот этот домик всё
бросил и отшельником стал короче вот и
книги купил и читает с утра до вечера
книги короче говорит скажите пожалуйста
вот я
вот правильно он сделал и мы короче
разделились на два класса и давай короче
с такими деньгами можно было и так жить
Зачем он сделал мы короче всем зару зару
зару начался а в конце он оказывается
учился на каком-то факультете психологии
он сказал оказывают вопроса нет ответа
да короче а мы там убились И точно также
Вот наверное правильно реплика что с
годами Да она меняется как-то вот мнение
Да вот в молодости действительно я вот
читал Вот и читал Очень много цитат
успешных людей 1% таланта 99% усилия но
сейчас вот когда мир меняется вот меня
лично Вот например меня вот я вижу как
мир меняется Да вот рядом со мной Вот
баке сидит вот он инвестор и часто ко
мне приходят на занятия люди инвесторы и
я например говорю давай работай
туда-сюда А я знаю очень многие ребята
инвесторы которые в общем-то при
минимальных усилиях совершают такие
квантовые скачки И вот я это вот нашёл
понимание что мир изменился Да мир
цифровый Вот лично мой кумир является
ник вучич Вот у него нет рук ног а он
богатый Да вот вот так совсем говорить
Да я хотел бы сказать что в моём
понимании что работать надо но если есть
интенсивность Труда есть понятие
рационализация да то есть вот работать
головой сейчас надо Вот именно вот
работать головой второе Вот как я хочу
сказать что сейчас вот изменения в
менеджменте таковы что раньше нам нужны
были активы Да вот собирать здания там
вот активы если 2.000 МТ меньше это
неприлично там если рентабельность
меньше 20% это неприлично в то время вот
на площадке У нас есть такой тренинг
называется менторский поток и Например я
всех Обучаю кидать жонглировать вот
сейчас фактически В чём суть сейчас суть
менеджера становится в жонглирования в
жонглирования чужими активами Да чужими
какими-то энергиями и так далее и
наверное Вот это изменение которое
сейчас произошло что Вот смысл
заключается Вот наверное первое я сейчас
веду такую рубрику когда я встречаюсь с
успешными людьми вот как вы например то
я вот беру интервью и задаю примерно 10
вопросов и Один из таких вопросов Вот вы
успешные люди Скажите пожалуйста какова
доля везения в этом Успехе
99% случаев все мне сказали что везение
сыграло значительную роль в этом Успехе
и вот вот почему у меня разделился там
мир Да понятно что мы работаем упорно Я
слышал Там историю Чем больше я работаю
тем больше мне везёт но это не те все
случаи Это был такой случай вот условно
говоря шёл шёл устраивался на работу Там
там к майке и он вдруг одну фразу сказал
и она поменяла всю жизнь да поэтому
здесь мне трудно сейчас сказать я могу
сказать Вот итог Вот работать надо
первое не руками а головой первое
работать надо хорошо да работать второе
головой головой головой надо работать
вот сейчас вот мир изменился то есть
ваше мнение такое пахать надо но надо
пахать головой Да второе Да работать
головой надо работать рационально не
разбрасываться энергией То есть я считаю
нужно работать эффективно да то есть с
минимальными усилиями максимальными
поэтому должен быть наставник должен
быть наставник который тебя кратчайшим
путём доведёт А так можно убиться можно
убиться всю жизнь положить и остаться в
парикмахерской где 50 МТ вот я так скажу
Поэтому вот я наверное хорошо такую
мысль свою скаж Так вторая точка зрения
третья точка зрения у нас Я наверное
пахать это вот у меня было До
сегодняшнего ли у тебя пахать Да я с 18
Летка девушка улыбчивая знаете я и когда
вот создавала красивую одежду
национальную нашу Да я дизайнер я И шью
я и парикмахером была в салоне красоты
работала сама администратором была на
что техничку раз выдержи да техничку
было даже трудно иногда найти а сама и
техничка была на работе и во всех сферах
Просто мне было интересно на работа Я
просто пахала Бывало такое что я просто
вот сознание теряла временами пахала
работала и в то же время как вот как
телепортация да бывает же там раз
сегодня там в Дубае завтра там где-то в
Африке а потом обратно в Кыргызстане
Оказываешься Да И вот мы блогеры как-то
своей жизнь оказывается показываем так
что иногда наши подписчики не понимают
где мы в реальной жизни находимся Да и
они такие говорят ты когда-нибудь
отдыхаешь вообще ты человек или робот да
И вот я действительно вот с 18 лет
оказывается настолько работала что вот
как будто как будто я бежала вперёд в
неизвестном направлении но при этом я
кайфовала от всего этого мне это
нравилось Да И вот в этом году случилось
такое Что я вот села и думаю неужели это
вся моя жизнь да Когда я буду жить как
вот обычная мама женщина счастливая Да и
очень много кучу вопросов Когда уже в
голове Ну сижу размышляю Ду маю над
разными темами и я мне стало страшно я
тогда я тогда поняла что я пережила что
ли свою жизнь 35 свои как будто я мне
сейчас 65 или 70 что ли И вот как будто
у мене вот все мечты они вот
реализовались и вот я не знаю куда мне
дальше Вот идти хотела стать бизнесвумен
хотела собирать залы концерты давать
сниматься в кино Да
и сечас только хочу воспитывать детей и
вот сейчас у меня такое я наверное
хорошо отпахал сейчас хочу жить работать
с правильными людьми правильно
делегировать наверное но не настолько на
первом месте как пахать уже Угу хочу То
есть ты сторонник сейчас больше не
пахать тебя сама попала То есть ты из
того лагеря переметнулся просто знаете я
посмотрела очень много
автобиографических Ну фильмов знаменитых
певиц людей где они вот перед смертью
просто говорили что они ни разу не жили
человеческой нормальной жизнью Да и мне
как-то иногда становится страшно что
Неужели я так бегу Ну вперёд Неужели я
быстротечна настолько Да вот гонюсь за
чем-то может быть Ну многие мысли сейчас
меня
останавливают вот
так меня девиз пахать надо только в
спортзале А когда ты делаешь подход уже
Пахать не надо Там нужно получать
удовольствие вот поэтому Да я вот в
каком-то уже взрослом возрасте увлёкся
боксом и когда мне прислали сегодня
сценарий наше нашего подкаста пахать или
не пахать я задумался где я вообще пошу
и понял что я пошу только реально в
спортзале и вообще когда я забочусь о
своём здоровье
а долгое время я не мог понять как
вообще устроена вот эта система успеха
или неуспеха в том числе вот с малан
Калиевич Я у него спрашивал как у вас
макея сказал что те проекты когда-то он
сказал которые я сам инициировал я там
ну мне нравится люблю больше потерял А
где как будто бы Случайный там больше
заработал Для меня это очень тоже мысль
была интересная и у меня есть тоже Ну
учитель но он больше так бы Мой врач
семейный мой личный но очень глубоко
понимает мою уже физиологию мои личные
какие-то настройки и он подарил мне
очень крутую идею тезис исследовав меня
Как вообще у меня работают мозги что
э для меня например очень важно поймать
состояние
Аа и ловить его в день допустим 5 минут
эти 5 минут они дают намного больше а
продуктивных и правильных решений чем
например я я бы пахал весь день и
напрягал бы там мозги свои поэтому А ну
я нашёл путь к этому состоянию это
Например встаёшь утром отправляешь детей
в школу готовишь им завтрак потом
плавание потом чтение потом заполнение
дневника потом а гитара пение то есть
всё что тебе приносит удовлетворение
э в следующей половине дня там встречи
опять же с людьми и вот М это всегда
должно быть так как будто бы ты ловишь
рыбу условно Я люблю рыбалку и любая
деятельность а любой этап он должен быть
таким как будто ты на самом деле
наслаждаешься И когда ты наслаждаешься
когда ты делаешь эту работу как будто ты
ловишь рыбу ты вообще не пашешь ты не
ощущаешь просто вот этот ну немножко уже
попсовые понятие поток все эту книгу как
бы Перечитай но всё равно оно есть на
самом деле И когда ты вот таким образом
к этому подходишь то ты даже когда
углубляется в какую-то работу то ты не
пашешь Угу Ты всё равно находишься в
творческом состоянии всё равно в
состоянии удовлетворения каком-то для
меня пахать - это вот реально работать
на износ Вот это нужно делать когда ты к
чему-то готовишься когда ты тренируешь
своё тело это очень круто Но даже это
может приносить удовлетворение и радость
Если ты любишь на самом деле тот спорт
которым тыкаешь Хорошо Вас рассадили
получается жёстко пахать Жёстко не
пахать мы любим бокс Да интересно может
быть один спра
Разный подход Я вообще считаю так что в
жизни Пахать не пахать это Каждый должен
отвечать со своей точки зрения для
кого-то пахать это надо 24 часа Ну там я
утрирую там 16 14 часов пахать для
кого-то я таких тоже ного виде
этова эв
она такая стабильная эффективность или
равномерная А есть рывковая когда ты
знаешь там неделю отдыхаешь отдыхаешь
потом за один 2 дня так много де
выполняешь работы или там наоборот целый
день ходишь а потом за час-два
выполняешь огромное количество работы
Это зависит от темперамента человека и
каждый человек должен найти свой способ
выполнения работы то есть нет
универсального способа нельзя сказать
всем надо Пахать и нельзя всем сказать
надо не пахать каждый подбирает под свой
темперамент под свой характер вот если
говорить про мой случай у меня такая
ситуация так как я по жизни сам лентяй я
сам по жизни лентяй
но я Лене не даю проявиться потому что я
забиваю её со стороны никто не скажет
что я лентяй Но вот это натура лентяй
она меня вовремя останавливает от пахоты
Я с одной стороны по натуре пахарь но
лентяй и вот это лентяй не позволяет
личное пахать но когда надо я пашу у
меня схема которая меня устраивает И я
буду так говорить давайте так каждый
человек должен определить сам меру когда
пахать что пахать Но что обязательно в
любом деле если вы хотите достичь успеха
есть определённая доля когда надо пахать
как Безумный И вот я привожу такой
пример когда я строю какой-то проект
какое-то здание предположим сорока
этажное здание на уровне фундамента на
уровне первого второго этажа я пошу как
угорелый просто как угорелый я
контролирую каждую вещь
дальше 39 этажей строит команда моего
участия Меньше меньше меньше вообще
сороковой этаж Может быть там вообще из
пенопласта Я даже сам не знаю ну там
команда строит но я точно знаю что
команда уже никуда отклониться не может
потому что фундамент задан и Вектор
задан Вектор задан Темп работы задан Ну
всё она уже не может никуда отне но
когда человек со стороны смотрит и видит
во ВМ здании я пахал только там 20% они
говорят кафо вобще не пахал я я не пахал
если брать всё здание я пахал всего 20%
Но эти 20% я убивался по полной то есть
там я и перфекционист Более того я не
просто перфекционист я ещё Параноик Но
почему Потому что
есть критические или я называю ключевые
точки приложения усилий усилия нужно
прилагать если у тебя новый проект Вот
именно на этой стадии Вот ты в этом
плане интуитивно правильно действуешь
надо задать культуру надо подобрать
правиль Люде надо выставить правильный
Темп работы потому что Темп работы тоже
от тебя и вот эти моменты то есть в
основе Когда вы закладывает фундамент
надо пахать много после этого меня очень
часто вызывает улыбку когда говорят вот
я хочу выйти из
операционки Я говорю Хорошо я согласен
Только скажи мне цель выхода из
операционки если у тебя цель выйти и
курить бамбук то ты потеряешь бизнес из
операционки можно выходить только по
двум причинам первое когда ты меняешь
Нелюбимый бизнес на любимый когда ты
выходишь из нелюбимого бизнеса
операционки начинаешь заниматься любимым
делом а второй случай когда ты уходишь
из операционки чтобы заниматься
стратегическими вопросами то есть
вопросами результаты которых будут через
2 3 5 лет то есть ты выходишь из
дущий этот гонок как белка в колесе и
занимаешься принятием решений результат
кото будет там через 3 5 10 лет только
единственная Причина выхода из
операционки и тогда что опять получается
ты вроде опять не пашешь потому что
когда ты занимаешься стратегией там надо
много отдыхать потому что суета
противоречит стратегии вот там ты должен
много отдыхать думать размышлять
заниматься своим здоровьем быть на
природе проводить много времени в
одиночестве и так далее состороны
человек который не понимает что твой
офис внутри твого твоей головы он думает
что ты не делае А это как раз то что
основные инвесторы делают инвесторы же
их основная работа - это приняти решений
Поэтому чем свежее голова чем она более
отдохну тая и чем меньше он задействован
в
суете тем лучше для инвестора Именно
поэтому инвесторы должны не спеша есть
Уфе хорошую фразу сказал гово Я за много
лет выл Такую форму чем больше движений
м меньше при
фраза богатейшего инвестора в мире чем
больше движений тем меньше прибыль и вот
здесь нужно тоже понимать когда ты
бизнесмен это одно когда инвестор другой
Но самое главное Самая суть на начальном
этапе первые 20% Ты должен пахать как
угорелый остальное ты занимаешься
стратегическими вопросами и не пони не
паже в том классическом понимании как
люди думают это как раз к вопросу когда
применят руки ноги а когда принимать
голову так вот первые 20% времени ты
должен и и ноги и глаза и голова всё там
потом ты
высвобождаемой Давайте
теперь поговорим о такой вещи Хорошо У
каждого своё мнение я своё мнение
высказал вы своё но я заметил такую вещь
что каждый раз когда мы Пашем А у наших
усилий различная отдача Вы наверное сами
заметили какое-то дело чуть-чуть только
сделал
результат а какое-то дело па па как
будто в стенку упёрся вот как будто вот
воду в этом точишь не можешь результат
выжать и такие моменты я называю точки
приложения усилий то есть ключевые точки
приложения усилий Я хотел бы узнать из
вашего опыта Назовите там условно Ну
давайте три точки которые дали Вот такой
пра результат Я считаю Вот лично у меня
не три а
четыре ве е в общем-то первое Я всегда
считаю что точка успеха - это чёткая
постановка цели Вот всегда Вот я считаю
что Семь раз отмерь один раз отрежь
Короче говоря это первая точка которой
вот в вашем случае Да я прямо в моём
случае это прямо моя вот вот вот вот я
прям сижу и думаю короче это вот первая
цель второе Я считаю свою точку вот
воздействия на воздействие это
сфокусировать все усилия на какой-то
очень узкой вот вопрос Вот вот то что
сейчас говорите вы о том что
сфокусировать Я прямо вот на этом прямо
вот фокуси я прямо закон парта всё
лишнее убираю Ну я объясняю очень просто
вот дома
э вот вы же кушать готовите убираете Вы
можете это убрать Ну вы же так дорого
стоите что клининг надо заказывать там
готовить надо заказывать то есть от всех
непрофильных вещей нужно убирать то есть
делегировать вот просто делегировать всё
вот третья часть это терпёж вот терпение
вот просто терпение вот всё вот вот мы
поставим цель Всё теперь всё больше не
обсуждается просто вот говорят воина
никто не торопит вот военное искусство
бусидо говорит воина говорит никто не
торопит ну есть решение принято теперь
действую без колебаний всё вот нет
правды всё вот теперь принял решение
теперь идёшь Ну и четвёртое - это люди
вот коммуникация эмоциональный интеллект
вот четыре вещи вот на чём я делаю
всегда акцент первое от моей точки роста
Это точное понимание что будет через 10
лет Я хочу что я хочу через 20 лет
второе всё лишнее Убрать всё
делегировать всё отдать Да тяжелее ручки
ничего не поднимать только вот сидеть и
вот не знаю читать книги встречаться с
успешными людьми общаться там ну там
людьми которые одна идея может вообще
поменять всю твою жизнь третье - это
терпёж просто терпение всё не знаю как
хотите там спортом плаванием не знаю там
чем-то у заставить называю это там
жёстко плоско зоп Короче просто сел и
вот там всё плоско и на этом стуле
сидишь Короче пока не достиг цели Ну и
четвёртое - это конечно люди люди тебя
делают богатыми люди Вот я четыре точки
вижу усилий на которые я делаю ставку и
читаю работаю двигаюсь только вокруг
этих четырёх точек роста для себя Вот
это для меня четыре точки роста и
транслите интересно Вот пришло пока
расска Супер наставничество всё-таки
Только на на опыте всё-таки абсолютно
согласен команда и тот Темп который мы
задаём команде вместе начинаем двигаться
сразу назват меня команда кейс То бишь
результат и
нетворкинг закреплённый как это работает
Просто на примере
скажем фильма либо
ивента Расскажи как вот фильм Когда
создавали как вот последовательность
была Да вот во-первых есть крутая
команда есть Кука Манас ребята алдик
сценаристы которые пришли с идеей иде ко
мне как продюсер гот вот есть такая
здоровская идея но это Алмаз Хоррор это
большей риск я тут немножко был похож на
баке потому что это венчурная инвестиция
большо счёт кино потому что я рискую
Всем большой суммой денег для меня тут
либо всё либо ничего Ты можешь и в минус
уйти очень легко и а Хоррор история Она
никогда не практически не была успешный
в Казахстане были разные кейсы Ну вот я
думаю никто на скидку не скажет Какая
Хоррор успешный кассовый фильм обычно
это всегда были комедии там Разно
жанровые фильмы
Дада и мы решаем что вот команда мо мои
мои ребята сели посчитали и вот команда
решила что всё мы идём в эту пахоту мы
идём снимать кино А что такое кино это
не так легко как всем кажется это ночные
смены Тем более у нас там один кадр где
к не знаю кто смотрел дастур где он по
стенам бегает мы этот кадр снимали
четыре ночные смены Почему Потому что мы
снимали в июле и июль Ночи короткие А
нам нужна нам нужна Темнота И мы снимали
в 300 км от города в ауле там свои есть
трудности вести там команду больше
полусотни человек туда и уже месяц там
жить и куча разных работы расходы всё
время нервы пере бюджеты от неопытности
и тут первый ключевой фактор успеха Как
на КФУ это вот была команда по следующее
уже результат работа получилась
результат дор Ну конечно мы делали
Маркетинг это тоже всё команды команда
считаю это как бы это секция команды Мы
дошли до результата фильм Вышел в релиз
и за первую неделю собрал миллиард да То
есть получается ты упор делаешь на
команду на Да первое я сделал упор на
команду который дал мне кейс результат
Угу ээ благодаря этому кейсу мы получили
во-первых деньги очевидно в Славу и эта
Слава дала мне дополнительный творк даже
вот мы с вами первый раз знакомимся
сегодня но большинство знает дост да и у
меня уже если раньше когда я был
студентом я работал нкейс для меня
ключом для многих разных дверей
корпоративных банков Был Была визитная
карточка нкейс да да Я всегда умел
использовать те или иные ресурсы которые
были под руко под рукой Я просто кейс
Всё окей Мы те сделки делали я могу вам
помочь также и здесь у меня есть те
визитные карточки которые результаты
кейсы которые мне помогают достигать ещё
большего успеха которые дают мне
дополнительный творк и люди посмотрев
наш фильм А мы ещё делали разные
концерты фестивали акционеры тех или
иных компаний директора им всё-таки
хочется тоже быть как-то
там подзь такие-то вот эти кейсы как я
назвал Да я прихожу и кладу их на стол и
мои контрагенты такие смотрят Окей очень
успешная истории Мы готовы отдать тебе
на подряд там такие-то такие-то объёмы
из наших компаний то есть второе ты
обращаешь внимание на то чтобы у тебя
были кейсы Да команда кейсы и третье -
это Нетворк который нужно закрепить
потому что имея такие крутые успешные
кейсы и правильно их Как мы называем
упаковать ты получаешь доступ к людям с
ресурсами которым тоже создаёшь для них
кейсы Угу И вот этот Нетворк важно
закреплять в моём случае результатами
когда твой клиент настолько доволен тем
что ты сделал во-первых он на тея
наслышан очень хорошо вот твои кейсы
Алмас а потом ты пришёл ещё для него
сделал такой же успешный кейс для него
самого ну и тут просто прелесть
соответственно если мы говорим Как как о
бизнесе Да и имея таких там топ 10-20
крутых больших в этой стране или не в
этой стране клиентов таким образом
бизнес и растёт потому что и для команды
появляются Новые горизонты и оборотка у
нас растёт и чистая прибыль у нас растёт
и там вот дальше уже детали вот
попросили три столпа для меня это
команда кейсы СШ результаты и Нетворк
который мы закрепляем с клиентами потому
что результат сколько я могу классно
рассказывать что вот я вот скоро сниму
фильм да Третий десятый но результат
говорит же громче всего за себя Да но
это вот то на что ты обращаешь внимание
это вот эти три вещи три вещи да ба
хорошо Бах А ну у меня наверное всё
попроще в плане мотивации Да я наверное
каких-то примерах попробую это показать
Вот ты на что обращаю вот свои инвесторы
На что ты вот что для тебя
Ключевое Да у меня был такой случай в
жизни когда я ушёл с госслужбы я очень
был успешным чиновником в нацбанке и у
меня был не очень добрые отношения то с
Марченко сложились я вынужден был уйти и
он когда увольнялся он сказал Ты крутой
госслужащий но ты очень плохой бизнесмен
а я И то и другое я вот взял лицензии
все и мы решили с партнёром заработать
там 10 мл что ли долларов там и мы
заработали буквально за очень короткое
время эту сумму
а
потом случился
кризис lon Brothers и мы все потеряли
ещё минус 2 млн мы должны были своим
друзьям Я помню это состояние Я только
женился и у меня там маленький ребёнок и
ты ты нужен То есть извиняюсь тогда ну
30 с копеч А ну вот да можешь ещё у тебя
ещ это впереди
Наверно это не точно но возможно Вот и
вот я помню это состояние это первое это
конечно стресс реакция организма когда
ты Как ты вчера был куче Денег которые
не знал на что потратить я реально не
знал на что это потратить А сегодня ты
ещё должен и вот этот момент когда у
тебя есть семья Когда у ответственность
перед людьми командой наверно
ответственность для меня это са самая
большая
са боль Стимул к тому чтобы двигаться
что-то делать и второй случай который у
меня натол на эту мысль У меня когда-то
очень достаточно большую для меня сумму
взял один человек чтобы построить Ну
здание квартиры там девелоперский проект
я инвестировал он уехал с этой суммой в
другую страну очень шумный был кейс и я
в итоге взял всё в свои
руки и
Достроил вклю свою лько включён что
полностью переосмыслил проект и научился
тогда строить дома я понял как как это
делать как этот бизнес структурируется
как это вообще всё устроено Я думаю Вау
какой кайф то есть если бы этого не
случилось наверное никогда бы этого и не
понял поэтому меня вот мотивируют две
вещи это ответственность перед теми
людьми которые во мне нуждаются о чём я
говорил в начале что это является
моделью успеха То есть когда я нужен а
второе может быть это
не очень нравится но трудности Угу Ну
это Смотри это то что мотивирует А на
что ты обращаешь внимание что ты
считаешь ключевым в своём деле в
инвестициях мне всегда кажется что я
вообще вот так устроен А я всегда готов
все деньги отдать на
инвестиции и мне моя жена всегда говорит
что
а оставь на ну на
развлечения на бриллианты и у меня меня
и Мне это очень нравится вот этот вот
Поиск этого баланса Потому что всегда
хочется Я всегда ищу те инвестиции
которые в моём там может быть не очень
широком восприятии но всё же меняют мир
как-то которые опережают то что понимаю
я то есть в твоём случае ты основное
внимание уделяешь
поиску проектов которы у меня всегда
есть какая-то там звезда которая вот
что-то что-то Невероятно инновационное
что-то чего я не понимаю что я хочу
познать вот и мне хочется отдать туда
все ресурсы но есть вторая сторона
которая это семья супруга те люди
которые ля ты внимание Направляешь на
поиск таких проектов А да они сами все Я
вообще их не ищу это всё само происходит
я не могу сказать что я какие-то усилия
к этому прилагаю просто мир так устроен
что давай назовём На отбор таких
проектов Если ты не ищешь они сами
приходят вот
на это это Ключевое ты считаешь
невероятное количество в этом мире умных
людей которые меня вдохновляют Особенно
это молодые люди которые там у которых
Вот ещё впереди какой-то какая-то стори
и я обращаю внимание на то
что имеет ли это
какую-то ну может быть революционное
будущее что-то что когда-то меняло я
помню как меняла жизнь интернет как
меняла жизнь
новые какие-то книги неважно в каком это
секторе мне очень интересна всегда вот
эта часть чтобы это взрывала мозг и мне
и
всем понятно То есть в твоём случае ты
ключевым считаешь
отбор проектов которые могут произвести
взрыв пшен и это ты определяешь через
молодых людей которые заряжены которые
прино Като то же время наверно очень
опять же возвращаясь к тому к нужности
человека очень выбирая вот эти все пазлы
ты конечно можешь выбрать какой-то
проект в долине но ты абсолютно там не
востребован потому что твои скилы там
казахские там совсем не нужны Поэтому
вот нужность твоя это тоже вот важный
пазл который Ты вставляешь вот в эту
конструкцию если она уже выглядит хорошо
Ты уже дальше то есть с одной стороны
поиск таких проектов и отбор с другой
стороны чтобы это было
нужно контролирует чтобы это было ещё
нужно людям нет
нужно людям это красивый тезис но это не
мой случай на самом деле ты говоришь
нужность нужность моя этой команде То
есть я не хотел бы ну я не выбираю
допустим инвестировать все стартапы они
у меня есть но где я вообще полный ноль
и никакого влияния оказать не могу Я
лучше выберу что-то с меньшим может быть
пока потенциалом но там где мои скилы и
моя Мои знания могли бы быть наиболее
полезными угу понятно
Анжелика в твоём случае что на что ты
прям обращаешь ни у меня чучуть наоборот
получается действия я быстро принимаю
решение пока думают Я люблю уже
потихонечку действовать Я больше
наверное смотрю на свои качества
какие-то Да какие у меня есть я их
приумножают и просто вот даже если не
верят в эти мои проекты Я всё равно сама
начинаю я рискую и у меня всегда как бы
получается всегда люблю быть первой
что-то необычное придумываю Ну не знаю
наверное это из-за того что А в
творчестве мы вот 10 альбомов Да вот
моих личных исполняю свои авторские
песни Я что-то там из этих исполнений из
этих песень там хит Угу я не знаю вот
Какая из этих моих песен Да вот взорвёт
и мы возьмём там песню года Угу Но
именно та песня которую мы просто
записываем на лайте там особо усилий и
как бы да ээ Ну не профессионально
скажем скажем так да отнеслись этой
песни но она всегда у меня бывает топчим
тоже самое ти вот в поддержку этой
версии Вчера только смотрел
а ну отрывок с нурланом МБА ем вечер
студия да да И там как раз был парень
Адам Привет его его песня журек более 3
млрд просмотров в тиктоке Он тоже
говорит
просто на лайте пришли мы говорит за 2
часа сняли клип просто всё вот так вот
просто и операторы оказались готовы всё
как-то как-то говорит даже чуть-чуть ну
не то что не профессионально как-то
получилось говори таж интересно
выстрелила и вот если Мы помним все
помним л Да там 2 млрд просмотров было
все такие Вау сейчас казахский клип 3 ЛР
просмотров поэтому когда мы выкладываем
рилсы или посты Я даже не знаю когда вот
я стараюсь Очень профессионально там
набираю команд придумываем стратегию
пишем Ну просмотров очень мало бывает А
вот такая вот я иду просто что-нибудь
там скажу на позитиве может энергия
действует что ли Я не знаю А там
миллионами у меня уже просмотры и
м фишка наверное в том что я это делаю С
любовью и на позитиве то есть на что ты
обращаешь внимание так первое действие
второе на позитиве это делат на лайте на
лайте и энергия я думаю там
вот в каждом успешном проекте есть
частичка меня где может быть я начала не
с большой сумму На сколько там надо было
да вложить в этот допустим бизнес-проект
бывают у меня такие проекты где я там
немножко вложила
но там люди подумали что это там
дорогостоящий проект и там вложились там
в 10 раз больше Да в разы и этот проект
у меня вот дал очень хорошего результата
Ну удача Ну я больше наверное на риске я
действую я просто действую я не жду
иногда бывает чуть-чуть подумаю и вот то
есть ты своё внимание де считаешь
ключевым
действовать на позитиве желательно и
передавать энергию Да обычно же люди же
богатеют потом только хотят прославиться
там ну знаменитость потом некоторым да
приходит а у нас вот у творческих
немногих людей Слава а потом богатство
ка приходит Угу У меня вот так вот
случилось Але ч для вас что Ключевое
Ключевое Ну наверное м вдохновение Угу
обязательно вдохновение Да Вдохновение
Вот Вдохновение Вот смысл понимания и
вот люди вот порядочность людей которые
потому что самые великие дела рушатся и
из-за каких-то субъективных каких-то
причин Да вот Вот наверное три вещи Вот
так бы я завёл бы интересно А почему я
завёл разговор о ключевых точках Дело в
том что очень важно ещё раз скажу вот
если достичь какого-то успеха вам нужно
сделать 100 шагов не все 100 шагов
равнозначны с точки зрения а результата
какие-то условно говоря как правило 80%
шагов это если по закону порд которые
можно делегировать не заниматься и так
далее или пустые и 20% каких-то это
которые оказывает максимальный эффект я
вот для себя чем ориентируюсь в жизни
всегда вот я для себя анализирую все
проекты чем бы я зани не занимался В
первую очередь я
всегда ищу смысл есть ли вообще смысл
этим заниматься Есть ли вообще надо ли
заниматься или нет Вот смысл для меня
вообще Это вообще всё вся моя жизнь
крутится вокруг смыслов я не занимаюсь
ничем что не имеет для меня смысла то
есть Вот смысл для меня прежде всего ну
смысл моей жизни Это моё предназначение
миссия вот а дальше смыслы проектов есть
Поэтому первое на что я обращаю внимание
и держу всегда фокус смыслу и каждый раз
я задаю вопрос Это для меня ещё имеет
смысл или нет Если не имеет я быстро
отказываюсь останавливаю проект выхожу
первый момент второй момент на что я
всегда обращаю внимание это намерения
вот я заметил от намерения очень много
зависит то насколько проект будет
успешным потому
что именно намерение это которая
включает все внешние силы или помощь
Всевышнего ведь Дело в том что вы же не
в вакууме живёте поэтому какую-то часть
пути вы проходите а какую-то часть пути
цель к вам приходит это как знаете ты на
лодке плывёшь можешь грести целый день
но если ты греш против течения ты стоишь
на месте А если ты плывёшь по течению то
цель сама к тебе плывёт это
необязательно тебе самому грести и
пахать поэтому 20% пахоты к ответу на
вопрос пахать это выбирать течение
правильное которое То есть самый
наиболее эффективный путь который тебя
приведёт к цели и не ты к ней Придёшь а
она к тебе ещё приплывёт вот это кстати
везение что и делает везение когда ты
случайно встал на то течение и так оба
уснул Проснулся цель уже вот она рядом а
поэтому я обращаю на намерение но
намерение - это такое как бы Триггер
который запускает когда ты выстраивание
вдруг появляются правильные люди вдруг
появляются ресурсы как-то это всё
начинает складываться весь пазл начинает
складываться Поэтому первое я занимаюсь
только тем что меня для меня имеет смысл
второе я
выстраивают у себя прямо в голове держу
и так далее это два момента третих
третий самый большой момент я всегда
прежде чем что-то делать А я сказал Я
лентяй в этом плане но у меня даже есть
тест такой пятины тест как откидывать от
себя все личные дела Я всегда зада
вопрос Если мне прилетает задача Я задаю
вопрос делать это не делать дальше
делать это самому или можно поручить
кому-то или делегировать третье делать
это сейчас или можно потом четвёртое
делать это в этом объёме или можно в
меньшем и пятое делать этим способом или
можно более лёгким способом то есть и
благодаря этому У меня 90% дел просто
отлетает
теперь что получается после того как я у
меня есть смысл и намерение Я смотрю на
эффект рычага
вот эффект рычага - это как раз то что
даёт наибольшее количество результатов
на наименьшее количество приложенных
усилий вот эффект рычага А что даёт
эффект рычага эффект рычага даёт знания
эффект рычага даёт
технологии эффект рычага даёт команда
эффект рычага даёт связи и эффект рычага
даёт
бренд Вот пять вещей которые позволят те
с наименьшими усилиями наибольшее
количество Реутов поэтому сначала смысл
потом намерение потом эффект ртга и
четвёртое на что я смотрю это на
накопительный
эффект накопительный эффект - Это такая
вещь когда ты делаешь что-то Один раз а
второй раз твоё участие уже
минимум Что даёт накопительный эффект
это
алгоритмы я
стари пионером алгоритмического обучения
Я как раз год с маргуланом запустил и
вот год с маргуланом 2.0 Он полностью
построен на алгоритмическом обучении а
там до нетна пошаговая система
алгоритмов где я взял все свои знания в
области бизнеса инвестиции личного
бренда личной эффективности и счастья
переложил на алгоритмы это огромная
работа и Человек идёт просто по
алгоритму и получает ответ на свои
вопросы так вот алгоритмизация вообще я
считаю смотрите каждый успешный человек
бизнесмен мне напоминает как гусеницу
знаете гусеница она идт здесь жуёт
поглощает события которые с ней
случаются А из задницы выходит вместо
вот у гусеницы паутинка же выходит А у
бизнесмена сзади выходит алгоритмы
алгоритмы - это то что тебе не позволяет
повторить эту же ошибку То есть ты уже
знаешь как действовать иначе твой опыт
бесполезен если ты из опыта не вывел
урок и этот урок не превратил в алгоритм
поэтому Что даёт накопительный эффект
алгоритм один раз продумал написал всё
Ты знаешь что эту ошибку больше ты
совершать не будешь дальше стандарты
алгоритмы стандарты шаблоны чек-листы
заметьте все крутые компании Возьмите
авиацию она полностью состоит вот я сам
Пилот она полностью состоит из
чек-листов Возьмите любое опасное
производство чек-листы вот я прыгаю
например там прыгнул самого высокого
моста в мире там тарзанка там
инструктора
один читает другой отмечает Вот это
сделал это закрепил это закрепил это
закрепил это же
алгоритм чек-лист - это тоже
алгоритм в любом в любом деле
Космическая отрасль Какая любая сложная
либо опасная вещь Она работает только по
алгоритму никакого человеческого
фактора Поэтому если
суммировать когда я занимаюсь что я
делаю я Первое это
проверяю для меня цель без цели вообще я
не работаю в принципе но я проверяю
Имеет ли цель смысл для меня второе
Правильно ли Правильное ли у меня
намерение Потому что если у меня
намерение будет Неправильно то помощь
Всевышнего не будет то есть внешней
помощи не будет второе третье использую
ли использую ли я эффект рычага и
четвёртое использую ли я накопительный
эффект вот четыре вещи которые на
которые я прямо очень скрупулёзно Смотрю
Теперь давайте
дальше мы
обсудили Кто на что смо смотрит и на чём
держит внимание Я вот ещё хотел бы
сегодня более-менее мы сегодня тему
Пахать не пахать когда пахать где Пахать
и так далее более-менее это раскрыли А
хотел бы ещё раскрыть в связи с этим и
Следующий вопрос очень часто задают мне
такой вопрос
что многие люди испытывают чувство вины
когда
то есть вот это чувство вины когда
отдыхает Я уверен у тебя оно есть такое
ощущение что жизнь проходит мимо ты
упускаешь что-то и так как вы люди
успешные Вы наверняка прошли через это
тоже то есть ощущение что блин
неэффективно или зря я дни теряю или так
далее И вот это другая крайность
отдыхать или не отдыхать вопрос то есть
это две Роны одно меда с одно ны Пахать
не пахать это сразу ответ вопрос
отдыхать и неть Как вы вообще относитесь
к отдыху и я уже примерно догадываюсь
что Бахт скажет я уже отдыхаю очень
положительно очень положительно Да так
как вы относитесь к отдыху И вообще
Какова роль отдыха И вообще как вы
отдыхаете я признаюсь я хороший вопрос
Как отдыхаете я стремлюсь отдыхать я
безусловно убеждён в том что отдых нужен
но не умею со врем ещ опять же я же
говорю мы заложники того что с нами в
жизни произошло работа вот
в в этой фирме чтобы вы понимали в душ
ходил Таким образом у меня телефон стоял
стеклянная дверь и Телефон стоял на
Видном месте и Хоть даже и там окно
может западе но я настолько знал когда
звонит управляющий партнёр Потому что
его имя так длинно записано у меня Угу я
мог выбежать и поднять трубку Ужас из
душа Я из душа мог выбежать и поднять
трубку потому что почему это делал Я же
учился параллельно То есть я был на
бакалавр и в конце второго курса я попал
в эту юридическую фирму на практи они
Оставили меня нав всегда Угу но с одним
условием что ты будешь учёбу сам
вывозить и работе чтобы это не мешало
Угу и с ректором договаривался с
предательски составом что я буду
работать и с на работе что я буду
учиться я не хотел создавать такой
ощущение у руководство фирмы что Алмаз
вот он слишком много учится и он не
выделяет время работе фирмы и мне
казалось хотелось всегда создать
ощущение того что я доступен в любое
время во время лекций мог убежать пойти
поговорить и вот настолько я стал скажем
роботом в этом плане что это безусловно
заложило какие-то наверное неправильные
не знаю ценности либо привычки в голове
Угу я до сих пор помню что в какой-то из
своих ээ отдыхов где-то за границей Я
лежал Я больше переживал о том что
происходит у меня на работе это был не
отдых потому что ментально всё время был
в операционных процессах компании Угу и
хотелось бы сказать что вот я я
безусловно убеждён что отдых нужен но
так не научился по сей день отдохнуть
так хотя бывает что я езжу куда-нибудь
там на какое-то время Угу по работе либо
с кем-то встретиться это одна встреча
может быть но я остаюсь в этой стране
там на 3-4 дня чтобы сходить посмотреть
погулять но вот и ни разу ни за один
свой отпуск Я не почувствовал что вот
отдохнул что Возвращаюсь с новыми
энергиями с новыми идеями Это я
навязывали себе Вот ты же Отдохнул
Теперь надо работать ну когда ты даже
отдыхал всё равно думал о работе всё
равно думал о работе Вот вы правы типа я
не знаю было озвучено либо я вопросы
смотрел Что бывает что Стыдно когда
отдыхаешь
да и раньше с отпуска было тяжело
возвращаться в компанию когда ты работал
в фирме А теперь будучи сам владельцем
компании мне так же стыдно возвращаться
к себе в команду если на тебя смотрит ты
же отдыхал только что и мне охота И я
понимаю что это супер неправильно Ну это
и крем от загар наверное Ма Чтобы
сотрудники не узнали Ну вот я про то что
я понимаю что это неправильно что нужно
перестраивать э это отношение безусловно
но мне нравится что мы сидим на этом
подкасте много что для себя нового узнаю
и одна из причин почему я очень сразу
согласился прийти потому что где я ещё
бесплатно послушаю баке э же Васильевича
вас и новые знания Да вот отдых для меня
это я ни в коем случае не корчу из себя
жертву того что я не люблю отдыхать я
всё время Пашу я выделяю много времени
для отдыха но он получается очень
неэффективный Как как выясняется просто
потому что я не умею это правильно
делать Оказывается это отдельный процесс
который нужно освоить Я из-за своей Лени
либо не знаю глупости так не научился
это осваивать Поэтому вот сейчас даже
вернувшись там вот су умры которые по
сути это отдых да это же не работа там
провёл 10 дней Но я и физически и
морально даже както уставший сразу ни
дня не отдохнув дома после того что 10
дней там ходил стоял я пришёл на работу
я чувствую что я был бы наверное гораздо
эффективнее если взял бы паузу 2 там дня
эффективно отдохнув но я просто-напросто
не знаю как у Вот мо отношение и
практика того что происходит в мой жизни
те Большой путь самопознания
ещё безусловно и мне не стыдно об этом
сказать потому что ну молодец сейчас
сейчас будем размышлять Дава Как вы
отдыхаете Да я всегда говорю что мол -
это такой це который очень быстро
проходит да да и я хочу сказать что
сейчас время не умных людей сейчас время
технологий значит я уже сказал что
человек - это Мешок с гормонами Да
которые там и так и так и так поэтому
конечно всё что здесь рассказывается
конечно это уже всё пройдено Да вот как
всег гово там рок а хвост мамонта Да вот
и здесь я хочу сказать Конечно у меня
были когда-то такие чувства Да И вот эти
ошибки Конечно они накопленные ну сейчас
так как я сам на своей площадке
транслируют ограничивающее убеждения это
просто ограничивающее убеждения есть
специальные техники которые ты их
проходишь и вот это чувство у тебя
исчезает Да это вот как не знаю там Укол
тебе сделали короче и всё Поэтому если
честно сейчас не замороченный
говорите стакан наполовину полн либо
наполовину пуц Да всё зависит только от
это как ты на эту ситуацию А как вы сами
отдыхать как я отдыхаю Ну понятно
что я сам по своей природе технократ у
меня всё-таки вот есть график н график
смысл заключается так вот выкладываться
на полную Да на полную катушку Ну вот
грубо говоря работать по 0
Неде это вот Ну не обязательно ещ раз
говорю руками ни ногами читать Вот Ну
вот и так далее и и в то же время вот
выключаться и всё вот просто выключаться
У меня нет там таких вещей ой телевизор
смотреть нельзя короче а это оказывается
неплохо Нет у меня такого вот как
говорится сделал дело гуляй смело
поэтому есть регламент То есть я
стараюсь там и менти говорить что
обязательно там раз квартал А вот значит
обязательно там раз в квартал они должны
10 дней отдыхать вот выкладывайте на все
100 Но вот как вот сегодня макет сказал
та рывковая техника там да на все
полностью потом выкладываешь точно так
же у меня я вот если мне команда говорит
там по регламенту надо надо надо вот это
г выкладывает на все 100 но потом
выкладываются что это ну обычно для меня
самое это обязательно спорт вот ходьба
там не знаю плавание Ну вообще я сам по
своему психотипу Мне очень важно
уединение Вот уединение мне нужно просто
вот и когда вот мне нравится фраза как
Чем больше я узнаю людей тем больше
люблю собак
Да такая фраза Да когда всё
заканчивается Да когда понятно сказал
там вот есть растяжки эмоциональный
интеллект всё всё всё всё но когда всё
заканчивается Всё я хочу дома ходить в
трусах Короче говоря и хочу выключиться
и никого не видеть у меня есть сад и я
вот там не знаю обрезку деревьев делаю
там сажаю деревья разговариваю там
сколько это длится Сколько длится Нет
конечно очень быстро восстанавливаюсь
это не значит что это
когда Ну есть вот время Вот это время у
тебя еже Вот в это время ты выкладываешь
Ну и потом два раза в год по месяц
отдыхаю два раза в год вот просто
вот по месяцу прямо месяц отдыхаю вот
просто выключаю и всё Ну и стараюсь раз
в месяц неделю отдыхать просто вот
отдыхать Ничего себе У вас 2 месяца в
год ещё каждый четырёх недельный месяц
Ты не осуждай
пока нам с бам будет Вообще стыдно
говорить поэтому ты его осуждаешь
я сейчас думаю а мне рассказывать или
нет вообще да да да да да Ну я вот так
просто поэтому а в этот период у меня
нету там Я не стесняюсь я считаю что я в
общем сделаю всё правильно У меня нет
ограничены убеждений проработанный Так
что вот Живу своё удовольствие классного
назвали то что я сказал ограничивающие
убеждения да да Угу Так Анжелика как ты
Ну у меня с детства так Ну судьба может
быть такая Да что получилось
а на отдыхе работаем работаем ну приятно
с полезным и путешествуем и в то же
время отдыхаем позволяем как-то это всё
правильно Так расставить чтобы не
чувствовать себя виноватой Да и особенно
вот последнее время вот чувство вины
перед детьми наверно больше я такая
слетала сама в Бразилию Да Аля в амазоне
повела и дети такие на меня смотрят а
когда мы туда
полетим и вот приходится как-то
объяснять что у вас есть свои летние
каникулы и тогда постараемся посетить
вот одну такую страну такая ж Бразилия
интересная Да что я
свои только 35 увидела Бразилию А вам
всего лишь столько это да и ну цели
ставим Это то же самое что когда есть
порядок дома и есть правила внутренние
да то есть я уже совестью отдыхаю я
говорю что это надо это
входит как Рабочая поездка э входят мои
обязанности и я это должна показывать
мотивировать
аудиторию да И в тоже время как бы вина
конечно есть такая что и перед
родителями да то есть и на отдых их
нужно свозить но на отдыхе Я с мамой
например не отдыхаю Я служу больше чтобы
быть хорошей дочерью чтобы вот ей этот
отдых понравился рядом наверное с семьёй
там когда окружает дети это тоже большая
ответственность это
Прим всем словам включиться и просто вот
дать на время свой
Instagram все свои социальные Да вот
каналы где люди хотят тебя видеть каждый
день а ты этого не хочешь делать Ну вы
как-то заметили Наверное это всё я сама
делаю сама монтирую сама всё снимаю не
такого чтобы я кому-то это доверила
потому что там душа моя это мой почерк А
вот от этого не устаёшь
Нет Не устаю Видимо это как тоже самое
что я это кушаю воздух как вода наверное
с этим живу и привыкла чтобы обратная
связь обязательно была я вот с детства
привыкла обществу как эльз Да меня вот
так вот и они иногда бывают э такие
ограничения что не разрешают мне там не
выкладывать неделями реальные сторисы
Где я сейчас нахожусь да бывало что я
хотела ну тоже как другие блогеры
отснять а потом кусочками давать эту
пищу Да а хотят чтобы вот как раньше я и
вела свою страницу чтобы так и
продолжала что я вот сегодня нахожусь в
Алмате вот я приехала до студии вот
сегодня я на подкасте Ау да пожелать мне
удачи и это всё в моменте должно как бы
да происходить наверное и это мне очень
кор лай блогер больше Да ну сейчас вот
вот я научилась наверное не чувствовать
вины когда я далеко нахожу от дома ну ты
научилась работать отдыхая и отдыхать
работая да да Поэтому у тебя чувства
вели нет Потому что ты когда отдыхаешь
Ты говоришь Ну я же типа работаю Вот в
соцсетях типа публикую и так далее перед
детьми только было но а сейчас тоже нет
Дети выросли растут уже понимают и они
говорят мама уже скоро мы будем тебя
звать На отдых мы тебе будем дарить
Путешествие для тебя отдых какой отдых
хороший Как ты е проводишь Я не люблю
одиночество Наоборот мне нужен рядом
человек с кем я могу а поговорить по
душам с кем приятно будет мне кушать с
кем приятно будет мне наверное смотреть
один фильм или читать
и ну общ тема чтоб была Главное чтобы
рядом был человек Наверное я не люблю
одиночество я с ума
сойду но он какой пассивный ты лежишь
книжки читаешь или телевизоры или
сериалы смотришь или что а я хожу Я
люблю наверное больше люблю смотреть на
природу на закаты на рассветы смотрю на
больше
наверное растения Я просто вот сижу и
начинаю разглядывать Всё вокруг себя и
это это вот прямо не знаю я кайфую от
того что я вижу я благодарю каждый раз
вишне Да что есть у меня такие
возможности слышать звук природы я вижу
это О я хожу на своих ногах я это трогаю
Я чувствую вкус То есть наверное от
этого я больше удовольствия получаю
когда я ну после пандемии наверное ещё
такие многие вещи случились и в своей
тридцать п и были такие моменты когда я
лежала прикованная кровать несколькими
переломами да то есть я сейчас просто
счастлива от того что я хожу и
вот получаю удовольствие от ходьбы Да от
Ну я понимаю потому что я знаю Немного
её историю она попала в аварию И вообще
была угроза что она ходить не будет
Поэтому Ну такая очень тяжёлая Авария
была на самом деле И поэтому вот то что
Анжелика говорит что я благодарю за
вообще возможность ходить это реально
точно такая Я кстати Вчера буквально
тоже ходил вдоль речки и так шёл
кайфовал кайфовал Но это безотносительно
тебя я просто пришёл у меня там есть
точка Крайняя Я пришёл три раза палкой Я
с палками три раза палкой бью фиксирую
себе что мне надо наза я такой иду и
думаю А я люблю благодарить Всевышнего И
вот я всю дорогу шл и благодарил за то
что я могу сам ходить на своих ногах
вообще такой кайф испытал от того что
благодарил блин Слава Аллаху что я могу
ходить сам на своих ногах Это же круто
Просто просто круто интересно да поэтому
тебя очень хорошо понимаю так я отдыхаю
меня огромный опы в этом вопросе
раз пытался жить в других странах там
где отдыхать намного проще то есть в
Эмиратах жил на Бали несколько сезонов
там несколько лет дети учились в местной
школе там шикарная
просто среда коммьюнити и Казалось бы
вот иди и Отдыхай и вдруг я обнаруживаю
себя через там 2 месяца строящим дом и
ну на
продажу потому что невозможно сидеть не
у меня есть какая-то онлайн работа
рассматриваю но я думаю Дай я куплю
участок и построю несколько домов там и
включаю в это А что я я же вроде
отдохнуть приехал и потом я сделал для
себя такое удивительнейший открытие
которое сейчас для меня открыло
колоссальные возможности Я понял что
отдыхать нужно каждый день в не
зависимости от обстоятельств которые Где
ты находишься То есть ты не можешь ты не
привязан к какому-то месту к морю там
горам А я
рассчитал что
самым лучшим способом отдыха для меня
является это сон здоровый Угу я
выработал привычку ложиться в 10 часов
просыпаться там до 6:00 Ну в зависимости
от времени рассвета
и утром
продышать самый суперский отдых а
который даёт ресурсы и у меня Бывают дни
когда я за Я уже всё это слежу в
дневнички записываю когда я например
пошёл на день рождения к другу и вот на
днях это было и потом лёг в Ча ночи и
точно вот весь день уже такой что ты
требует тебе требуется отдых Ты уже это
чувствуешь что тебе нужно отдыхать что
ты не в ресурсе Поэтому в принципе когда
ты Изучи себя и выработает какую-то
модель которая позволяет тебе
восстанавливать твою батарейку тебе
неважно будет форма этого отдыха Но это
может быть просто простой сон второе что
я там музыку допустим я могу на гитаре
играть Там или стихи там писать какие-то
никому их не показывать потом но всё это
даёт каждый день тебе возможность
перезаряжаться и каждое утро просыпаться
с новыми силами Угу классно и не
обязательно никуда уезжать да А можно я
спрошу ещё А может быть такое что вот я
вот слушал и размышлял что я не разделяю
работу и отдых что в принципе я не Если
ты не устаёшь от работы Если тебе
нравится
процесс Давай я попытаюсь ответить
потому что я тот человек который очень
много рефлексирую
Как говорится ВС структури и это у меня
требует от меня больших усилий я
по-другому мыслить не могу у меня
операционная система заточена на это
поэтому Прежде всего я понял такую вещь
что Для чего Нам нужен отдых нам отдых
нужен только по одной причине для
восстановления энергии ну другой причины
нету отдых только для восстановление
энергии так вот когда ты занимаешься
делом которое является твоей миссией
то ты в обратку получаешь так много
энергии что ты можешь гореть целый день
ты горишь целый день у тебя энергия прёт
это знаете когда костёр пылает
бессмысленно дополнительное дрова кидать
Зачем он пылает когда он тухнет только
накидывать дрова Так ведь Поэтому я
считаю что самый главный секрет отдыха -
это Заниматься тем делом которое
является твоей миссией то есть своим
любимым делом или дело ради которого ты
прил в этот мир предназначение для чего
тея Аллах послал на эту землю поэтому
когда ты занимаешься этим делом ты
горишь и ты не нуждаешься в отдыхе
потому что всё у тебя всё Ты в потоке ты
горишь тебе не нужен отдых никакой это
самое интересное чем бы ты занимался и
всё но при этом есть ограничитель наше
физическое тело оно не может духовно
эмоционально ты заряжен можешь работать
а тело может отказать поэтому ял для
себя такую практику
сказал но я перевёл прямо в алгоритм
практики у меня Я работаю так я работаю
час из которых 45 минут работаю 15
отдыхаю я это называю контейнеризация
времени когда у меня контейнер под
задачу час из которых 45 минут работы 15
минут отдыха То есть я не не жду пока я
устану У меня просто отдых вшит в
выполнение задачи когда я выполняю
какую-либо задачу обязательно после
задачи я делаю отдых для чего это нужно
потому что время я там Пью чай кофе и
вознаграждают те люди которые достижение
успеха превратили в привычку а привычка
- это когда ты ставишь цели делаешь
действия получаешь результат и
вознаграждает должен себя тренировать
как собачку Ага прям будильник ставите в
45 минут А у меня есть помодора такое
часы будильник Да это уже становится
знаешь как второй натурой Ты даже у меня
уже этот будильник стот я даже не смотрю
автомати Да если Смотри у меня задача
меньше часа меньше 45 минут тогда я
пытаюсь две задачи сделать если больше
то всё равно делаю перерыв поэтому я это
называю у меня вот в этой книге кстати
есть она называется контейнеризация
времени есть у меня кластеризация поняти
времени А есть контейнеризация времени А
и таким образом я всё время стараюсь
таким образом делать что работа и отдых
- это в одном контейнере я их не
отделяют это работа А вот это отдых а
вот это
я искусственно делаю Потому что когда ты
занимаешься любимым делом есть обратная
проблема остановиться
невозможно и вот это прерывание это как
предохранитель он такой говорит всё
остановись пофиг что ты увлечён
Остановись я встаю из-за стола хожу там
что-то делаю Мне надо короче что-то
делать это отдых эти 15т Потому это
отсе в рате нет благодар очень долго
заниматься делом А так ты можешь сесть 3
часа поработать потом встать спина а не
можешь разогнуться и так далее Поэтому
вот это второй лайфхак первый - это
миссия и занятия любимым делом второе -
это когда ты занимаешься любимым делом и
ты в потоке проблема остановиться и
чтобы этого не было я отсечение делаю
иначе тело не выдержит эмоционально ты
готов уха но тело не выдержит поэтому я
делаю такие
отсечки И третье я
по крайней мере на своём опыте Я знаю
что существует четыре вида энергии
первое физическая энергия потом
ментальная энергия потом эмоциональная
энергия потом духовная Энергия и я понял
Из своего опыта
что Отдыхать надо именно той энергии
которую ты
потратил и Бывает так что ты вот я сижу
читаю думаю алгоритмы пишу и так далее
особенно вот последнее время я оче много
алгоритмов имен для програ
я устаю А чем я устаю я так в себя
смотрю вроде ещё могу блин брёвна
таскать то есть не по физике я устал и
не эмоционально устал я устал ментально
это ментальная энергия у меня кончилась
А вот Я размышлял Что такое ментальная
энергия я понял такую вещь ментальная
энергия - это единственный только
показатель Это твоя способность
концентрироваться на
чём-то это вот в твоей фронтальной коре
это активность коры головного мозга то
есть электрически импульсы так вот когда
ты читаешь отчёты или книгу Или думаешь
ты устаёшь и уже не можешь
сконцентрироваться вот ты глаза читают
текст а мысль теряешь теряешь мысль и
так далее это значит у тебя ментальная
энергия кончилась Угу И вот как надо
отдыхать когда кончилось ментальная
энергия два способа первое полный
расфокус деконцентрация а это лучше
всего делать смотреть на огонь на воду
А и на на природу либо медитировать то
есть
главное полностью отключить любую
активность мозговую
Поэтому нужно из размышления перевести в
наблюдение когда ты Наблюдаешь за
каким-то процессом ты это отдыхаешь либо
второй способ - это так как первый
способ не всем даётся Ну не у всех может
хорошо а второй способ - это просто
начать концентрироваться на другом на
другом Чтобы другие части мозга активно
работали например начинаешь играть пинн
Там же ты тоже
концентрируя ты на мячи этого
концентрация это другой участок мозга
работает а вот этот участок отдыхает
поэтому либо деконцентрация либо смена
фокуса это когда ментальная энергия Ну
когда физическое легко там поспал
отдохнул поел там ты знаешь когда
физически устал да вот этим как раз все
могут управлять А вот ментальное
расслабление - это вот восстановление
Вот это теперь эмоциональное когда
наступает эмоциональная усталость и вот
выгорание потеря мотивации и так далее
когда ты общаешься с с большим
количеством людей отдаёшь очень много
энергии и баланс не в твою пользу когда
ты там много негатив ков ты отдал много
100 едини а получил взамен 70 отдал 100
получил 70 у тебя вот этот дефицит
накапливается и через несколько дней
общение с такими людьми ты весь выжатый
как лимон физически ты можешь брёвна
таскать от что ты можешь читать но
эмоционально ты не хочешь ничего делать
и не хочешь видеть
людей это эмоционально пере когда
эмоциональная энергия кончилась так вот
Когда у тебя кончается эмоциональная
энергия надо восстанавливать
эмоциональную энергию не физическую не
ментальну А эмоциональную как
восстанавливать эмоциональную энергию
Это один вариант это идти в круг где
обратный баланс где ты получаешь условно
130 единиц а отдаёшь там 100 единиц это
что ты идёшь на вечер юмора например где
все Хохот ржут и так далее ты ид Круг
близких друзей где ты можешь не тратить
эмоциональную энергию А они тебя
поддержит и ты получаешь энергии больше
а третий вариант - это вообще хорошо
ходить в круг увлечённых людей вот я
люблю ходить в круг там парашютистов Я
люблю альпинистов люблю пилотов люблю в
авиации они все глаза вот такие горят им
деньги нету понятия денег это люди
которые горят своим делом увлечены
дельтапланерист они такие И ты такой о
них сильно
заряжаешься либо восстановление
эмоциональной энергии способствует
хорошо это природа и
экстрим когда ты Вау выброс гормонов
такой идёт ты такой Вау там короче нужно
такое чтобы для этого значит купание в
холодной воде шикарно восстанавливает
эмоциональную энергию ты идёшь просто в
горную реч купаешься выходишь
а есть ещё такой метод когда ты
выкрикивает энергию идёшь в уединённое
место и просто
орёшь Да работает потому что смотрите а
фишка управления энергией кстати здесь я
тоже описываю фишка управления я Power
менеджмента даже науку такую для себя
изобрёл фишка управления в том что у нас
никогда не бывает что ноль энергии
просто смотрите у нас бывает Светлая
энергия падает
а тёмная энергия автоматически заполняет
её место Почему приведу пример ты идёшь
с работы уставший
хо когда ты Голодный уставший холодный у
тебя нету силы воли заметь сила воли
подпитывается за счёт позитивной энергии
у тебя нету дисциплины потому что это
дисциплина тоже за счёт светлой энергии
подписана ты не
благородный ты не щедрый ты не готов
слушать чужие проблемы и ты злой вот
заметь когда у тебя нету эмоциональной
энергии сказать что ты истон Да нет ты
сейс скажи Разбей посуду Да ты здесь всё
перекрашивать да Ты так прекрасно это
сделаешь понимаешь то есть по сути дури
то у тебя много но получается не та что
тебе нужно У тебя вот в этом мире баланс
светлой энергии тёмной энергии тёмная
энергия вот в мире зла и тёмной энергии
как темноты в ночном небе звёзды нет а
светлой энергии как количество звёзд но
здесь плохая новость то что кажется зла
и тёмной энергии больше но хорошая
новость в том что свет всегда побеждает
тьму свет всегда побеждает тьму то есть
Светлая энергия побеждает поэтому для
того чтобы восстановить эмоциональную
энергию это Пойти прокричать Пойти
искупаться в холодной горной
реке испытать какие-то экстрим
эмоциональные эмоции яркие либо пойти в
обществе где баланс в твою пользу Вот
это восстановление эмоционально но
крутая энергия - это духовная энергия
духовная энергия она как золото валюта
она может конвертировать в любой вид
энергии она может конвертируется в
физическую энергию в ментальную энергию
и в эмоциональную Как это
работает вот это ещё такое было
наблюдение что в концлагерях и в тюрмах
дольше всего
выдерживали
коммунисты Угу а потом религиозные То
есть получается дольше всего верующие а
перед ними коммунисты то есть и
получается так что они терпели невзгоды
голод холод ужасные условия и так далее
так вот это духовная энергия духовная
энергия - Это такая вещь которая делает
нас по сути людьми когда ты голодный
холодный и уставший именно духовная
энергия превращается в твою
эмоциональную энергию и ты готов
поддержать слабого Вот это отличие
человека от образованного условно говоря
духовного человека не духовного потому
что не духовный человек когда он
уставший он с Завтра приди Иди отсюда а
духовный человек он не позволит себе
потому что духовная Энергия
конвертируется в эмоциональную и он
готов выслушать даже у него самого сил
нет а способность духовных людей не имея
сил проявлять эмпатию так вот или не
имея физических сил продолжать идти
продолжать идти и что-то делать
поэтому духовная энергия это са крутой
вид энергии который надо накапливать
потому что это самая ликвидная часть
энергии которая заменяет любой тип твоей
энергии Угу Как восполняется или
приобретается духовная энергия Я заметил
Каждый раз когда ты думаешь о вечном
Каждый раз когда ты думаешь о смысле
жизни Каждый раз когда ты думаешь о
своей миссии Каждый раз когда ты
посещаешь могилы Каждый раз когда ты
посещаешь религиозные учреждения храмы
там мечети и так далее и так далее
Каждый раз когда ты ведёшь беседы о
вечном Каждый раз когда ты
Оказываешься
духовная энергия она тоже тренируется
чем большую щедрость ты проявляешь тем
больше эмпатию сочувствия бедным или
несчастным людям ты Оказываешься
и интересно что радость мы испытываем
горнов
гонов счастье - это духовная история Угу
счастье - это духовная история Когда я
называю это не так что там бурная
радость А когда ты имеешь такую тихую
спокойную уверенную радость такую у тебя
она радость внутренняя но она такая
спокойная Тихая такая уверенная у тебя
нету беспокойств у тебя нету лишних
страхов Ты любишь весь мир Ты любишь
всех людей каждую букашку А И этот мир
прекрасен ты преисполнен благодарно Вот
это счастье вот это как бы наполняет и
делает нас счастливыми поэтому Источник
счастья - это духовная энергия поэтому я
вот для себя
структурирующий Интересно так что вообще
управление энергией - это вообще такая
крутая тема вот рекомендую я не не
рекламирую и эта книжка на самом деле не
должна была попасть в кадр Это мой
подарок просто вам как участникам А
давайте начнём подводить итоги мы уже
достаточно много сидим во-первых Давайте
отрезе то о чём мы сегодня говорили Итак
мы сегодня говорили о том что пахать или
не пахать а в целом Дайте небольшую
обратную
как-то Измени изменилась ваша точки
зрения на это или
нет давай с тебя у нас схема уже
сложилась не ломай работает
же не безусловно Это было очень полезно
послушать особенно вот концовка про
усугубление что оказывается Если ты
восстанавливаешь не ту
энергию неправильны
методом для ня это было пр открытие ЕС
чест при думать об этом
теперь по поводу моей позиции пахать или
не
пахать Я наверно пересмотрю свои взгляды
касательно отдыха и вот каких-то вот
деталей которые мы обсуждали потому что
я вот посчитал пока мы сидели обсуждали
МАСИ ка 4 с по месяца отдыхает в
году може се позволить я я тебе скажу
свой график у меня я не работаю больше
250 дней в году и не более 6 часов то
есть у меня чёткий бюджет по чав Я
только в году
работаю пря Это причём по это с учётом
моего бренда Вот это съёмки это у меня
работа это бренд мои путешествия вот в
Бразилию Мы приехали сейчас это
работа это работа потому что я когда
путешествую Ты же видела Я же ещё
разборы провожу и так далее поэтому это
работа то есть поэтому я ну в год я
вообще отдыхаю стыдно сказать наверно
месяца четыре
минимум Может пять Вот соответственно на
этих двух примерах я пересмотрю свой не
Ты должен понять такую вещь что отдых
должен быть частью работы как
контри я Поня что работа часть отдыха
нужно прочитать во-первых эту книгу для
того чтобы это понять во-вторых всё-таки
я остаюсь на той позиции что мы ещё на
взлётный как мы же сказали да несколько
раз что надо безумно пахать определённые
этапы ещ Да ещё хочу сказать добавить
такую вещь в голове вот Василь сказал
Самое главное ограни убеждение те надо
убрать что прямую связь между
количеством работы и результатами вообще
нету никакой Ну не то что Никакой она
связь косвенная да то есть количество
работы никак не приводит к количеству
результатов они не прямо коррелируют это
избавиться как ногу отрезать тяжело
будет сделать но нужно будет
потренироваться наверное но в целом
Да на любой мой довод дали другие
аргументы сейчас получается не нужно
подуть на тебя
смотрим ты такой пар ты нам создаёшь
чувство комплекса и вины а у меня
наоборот вы создаёте как будто у меня
очень много в пустую как будто бы работа
делается холостую мы пытаемся тебя в
этом убедить чтоб ты начал как мы
бездельничать но я думаю что в моём
возрасте Скорее всего тоже пахали так
как я похоже даже больше конечно тоже
нет не так не так точно не пахал я может
быть даже меньше работал Ага Да Ну вот
нужно подумать нужно почитать бывают
вопросы вот что мне
э не нравится во многих скажем подкастах
у всех на всё есть ответы все во всём
специалисты наверное вот этот вопрос
который вы сказали мне ещё нужно Я люблю
говорить что я не знаю если я не знаю
мне ещё нужно время анализировать
подумать и прийти к кому-то ответу
поэтому зрители от меня чёткого ответа
даже по моей собственной позиции ещё не
получит потому что мне нужно больше
времени для этого хорошо такой у меня
ответ да у нас а то этот комплекс такой
неполноценности мы мало
Пашем спасибо
ну прежде всего наверное Вот это
интересное вот обмен энергиями я конечно
Получил сегодня обмен с превышением Да
скажем так такая вот заключительная
часть это малан колич конечно нас
вдохновил да В общем дал такую энергию
Ну я наверное уже не в том возрасте
менять привычки Так что уже есть своя
формула успеха в жизни да и Наверное
поэтому и пригласили наверное за этим
Как говорится столом именно наверное
очень ещё раз от тебя услышал что жизнь
прекрасна что мы все разные Вот это
наверное очень важный момент что мы и
отдыхаем по-разному
и мыслим по-разному именно то что мы вот
все по-разному мыслим и вот друг друга
дополняем да Я всегда говорю у тебя 10
идей у тебя 10 идей вместе не 20
несколько 100 идей Да несколько
несколько сот идей Вот точно так же
здесь вот пять человек встретились да
такой огромный синергетический эффект Я
прямо получил такое вдохновение и это то
что называет Вот я считаю вот гм подкаст
мне чем нравится это такое роскошь
человеческого общения Вот именно вот это
то есть нет у нас цели там переубедить
друг друга каж уже состоялся у каждого
своё мнение есть но когда мы на стол
раскладываем и такие начинаем Так что у
тебя там такие О какой кайф кайф О я вот
это возьму от тебя а вот это от тебя
возьму кайф кайф кайф Да да вот это
наверное да вот прямо вот наверное
подытожить можно так в общем кайфанул
вот прям тако заряженный прямо Огромное
спасибо за приглашение спасибо
Присоединяюсь к словам Ну я дошла до
середины книгу сес же не сейчас я по
пути Поти читаю Да технологию счастливой
жизни я абсолютно согласна м полностью
Да что там написано и для меня сейчас
вот новое открытие Как заняться ещё
одним новым видом бизнеса это как Где
твой бизнес а легитимный просто я
оказываюсь занимаюсь Именно таким
бизнесом где я рассказываю о своём
бизнесе никаких секретов нету при этом
поддерживает меня народ и также и никто
не может как бы докопаться да до моих
бизнесов вот легитимный маленькую
ремарок сделал легитимный бизнес в этом
в этой книге я рассказываю есть законный
Бизнес есть легитимный закон - это когда
вы делаете бизнес не нарушая законов А
легитимный бизнес - это такой бизнес при
котором общество признаёт за вами право
на ваше Богатство и вот теперь думайте
Как делать такой бизнес это значит
помогать людям это значит заниматься
только полезным бизнесом это понятно не
пользуется монопольным положением и так
далее Всё что в исламе сказано и я
сейчас глубоко понимаю чем я занимаюсь
благодаря вот последней нашей поездке я
получила почти сказать 99% На все свои
вопросы-ответы Я очень благодарна что
команда именно Да ответили мне и даже
сюда вот сегодня пригласили такой вот
прям или как коллаборация у нас так
прямо сейчас получилось Я сегодня тоже
На многие свои вопросы да в голове
которые у меня были получила ответы
Спасибо вам
Ну подытожить если Ну я иду правильно
значит духовно и энергично Я умею
восстанавливаться Я наверное
значит по своей
а интуиции Да правильно наполняю энергию
которую я
расходуют или не пахать Ну наверное
сейчас вот золотую середину буду держать
Также хочу не пахать пахать Когда будет
настроение по желанию и желаю чтобы вы
никогда не переставали мечтать я вот в
ходе нашей беседы как-то не знаю может
быть неправильно сказала что я не знаю
теперь о чём мечтать Да ну мечтаю о том
чтобы
м мы были нужными и оставались просто
вот Человеком хорошим Как наш великий
писатель сказал чеги зат матов человеку
каждый день трудно быть человеком Да ам
десь остава мо любимый писатель Да
просто
человеком не то что просто человеком
полезным Да класс
Ах мне легче всего потому что я как тот
юный гость которому последнему НАТО
казахском слово дают уже все всё сказали
ты уже знаешь все имена все там эти
характеристики Ты уже говоришь я
присоединяюсь ко всему сказа супер
Угу
завершают наша сегодняшняя беседа -
это и с одной стороны
м полезное дело а с другой стороны и
отдых и восстановление вот то что вот вы
говорили мы
свой эмоциональную Да энергию и духовную
и вы так очень хорошо рассадили здесь
вот таких более
практиков Да и мы получили друг от друга
очень много энергии это очень круто и я
вот даже сам я всегда когда вас слушаю А
всегда понимаю что я-то интуитивно ко
всему иду я вот так вот расставил
например что мне нужно рыбу ловить и
песни допустим петь Ну зачем а у меня
спрашивает преподаватель зачем вы вообще
ходите на пение Я говорю а у меня здесь
останавливаются мысли Угу Или например
Зачем ты идёшь на бокс А у меня здесь
перезапускается определённые механизмы
лка и пед да Или допустим что-то я вот
так выстроил свой график я даже не знал
что можно на четыре части
систематизировать и сделать из этого
алгоритм но кто-то идёт к этим
алгоритмам через методы проб и ошибок А
кто-то изначально просто умеет эти
алгоритмы строить но и это и круто когда
есть возможность а всем это этим опытом
поменяться потому что в принципе Каждый
из нас он восприимчив к каким-то
инновациям То есть это для меня тоже это
сейчас инновационный подход И я тоже
сейчас постараюсь алгоритми Зро всю эту
методологию свою личную Может она
кому-то тоже поможет в будущем наладить
свою жизнь классно Итак дорогие друзья
наш гем подкаст потихоньку подходит к
концу Мы уже резюмируем на самом деле
сегодня мы
рассмотрели очень хорошую такую группу
вопросов из которых два самых главных
пахать ильный Пахать и второй вопрос как
отдыхать когда отдыхать и так далее Я
думаю это два таких дневных вопроса А вы
сегодня увидели пять точек зрения и все
здесь успешные люди и у каждого свой
подход и очень важно но в то же время
есть определённые общие принципы которые
наверное надо
знать поэтому мы сегодня постарались
максимально вам принести пользу Надеюсь
что этот эфир был очень полезный поэтому
Если вам понравилось Подписывайтесь
ставьте лайки комментируйте интересно
будет почитать ваш подход о том как что
вы выбираете Пахать не пахать если
пахать то сколько пахать что вы
выбираете отдыхать и как вы вообще сами
отдыхаете перейдите с нами в дискуссию
Пишите в комментариях До новых встреч
Всем спасибо спасибо до свидания